alors les séries tient pas seulement à
gaza nous les couacs et l'animateur le
plus stylé nikos très bien déviée nick
australien habitera voulez vous
rattraper parce que vous avez des soucis
avec lui non je n'ai pas de souci avec
lui mais il est très bien habillé
d'accord non moi c'est moi je suis assez
d'accord il vraiment il tout s'est
toujours bien sûr mot c'est énoncer
tressé sourit le plus mal habillé c'est
qui à bas la ccbbo nos visions bruno
guillon or voilà ben bof c'est pas vrai
alors il est pas mal habillée d'une
hanche au camp nou avec votre pull de
pompiers si l intervention c'est en tout
cas le style de celle ci lui correspond
pas ces anglais et voilà c'est pas
tellement
baptiste est en porte voix qui le roi du
style bien fort c'est vrai que bruno il
est un petit peu un petit peu rond à la
presse que ça ça lui correspond
parfaitement je pense pas non plus
annoncé que tu la dirai comment toi j'ai
pas c'est en tout cas j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas très assumé transparence
et en jogging en sarouel
[Applaudissements]
laurent delahousse mes amis laurent
blanc il est toujours voilà une sorte de
friday wear constant et j'aime bien ce
style un petit peu comme savoir si
laurent delahousse
pas vraiment non non parce que je suis
pas très fan du blond du blondinet bon
alors il est pas blanc partout non moi
je vous dis voilà j'ai il est blanc à
l'extérieur
oui mes bras l'intérieur cette manne
c'est comme un samedi mais c'est pas moi
c'est sur votre délire wave vous excite
pas non non voilà et dany madame la
merguez à l'émetteur du barbecue comme
anne n'a pas assez viril quoi est le
moins bien habillée patrick sébastien
ouais j'ai personne de sa veste bleue
alors justement t on à des ondes à des
avants après c'est vrai en plus on a d
abord après tiens regardez patrick
sébastien ça s'est arrangé mais la
maison bleue il faut qu'il arrête avec
cette facilité de la guitare il est
beaucoup plus beau maintenant il faut
qu'ils soient les plus forts et les
problèmes de songer avec la veste bleue
je n'aime pas cette veste bleue faut
qu'il arrête avec cette veste bleue mais
hélas peu coup là sur la tête de ma mère
la tête est folle
[Applaudissements]
après après de nikos aussi qu'un de
nikos de nikos aliagas
non c'est mieux la voile a alors regardé
nikos a maintenant et avant away
toujours lui serrer la main s'il avait
le petit truc mes frères il
il avait des sourcils dieu bénisse sur
la vie de ma mère frère il avait des
skis l'hiver à oued dieu bénisse les
sources à nous dire arthur ça va
l'opticien bout moi le mot vieux amis et
c'est jean luc reichman pas tellement
pour cette tenue actuelle mais surtout
pour les progrès accomplis en dizaines
d'années parce qu'il est parti de très
loin
ouais là où il arrivait ça les connaît
on dirait on dirait un fan de francis
cabrel
[Rires]
moi
les premiers guette san francisco des
promesses vous êtes sages et toujours
les douces et comme isabelle il a
plusieurs membres la gagner et ça il
avait plein fouet mais non parce que là
c'est d'époque il en vendait sur la
plage rien à voir avec le style
c'était d'une montre et deux soucis
c'est vrai qu'il est devenu très beau
monde en lousiane celle qui fait partie
de mes animateurs préférés non ils
évoluent pas il est toujours habillé
pareil cela classicisme oui mais non
c'est ça monte ça manque de fraîcheur ça
manque de près de 7
[Applaudissements]
c'est au bras ouais bah ouais mais moi
il est venu beau stéphane tombe bien
c'est parce qu'ils s'assument pas là il
est bien ouais c'est votre fils ses fans
j'aime beaucoup ce stéphanois à moi
aussi j'adore j'adore stéphane bern pam
a libéré billets ou pas ouais ouais
c'est toujours il sait mieux
après le coach à lèvres un peu bizarre
ouais nan rayures c'était pas top
brest est pas c'était pas ou feint il a
beaucoup et les shows lula d où ils
avaient une matière de cheveux très
bizarre ah mais oui il assumer passer
boucle à la célèbre chien exactement
connais bien le problème même quoi
connaissent à dire vers le problème
merci on fera un avant/après enfin on a
des photos vous avions d'une photo tu es
dans une grotte on a retrouvé alors pour
moi l'un des plus élégants du paf c'est
michel denisot toujours très élégant au
fur et à mesure des années le trouve un
oui c'est vrai ça vous êtes d'accord
avec moi bien sûr aller pour le non pas
le matin en avoir après que michel
denisot en avant après il n'a pas changé
c'est vrai à mes frères michel denisot
frère arrivé et le gas et igor et
grichka quoi et donc ouais c'est pour
moi quelle moins évident moins bien
habillée c'est vincent ferniot on
retrouve un midi en france avec les
chars
[Rires]
audard
ah ouais quand même là on voit que c'est
le gars qui veut pas s'endetter mal
habillés oui tu veux que je te foute une
échalote de la gueule je vais la trouver
je vais te mettre un piment d'espelette
encore là ça va mais lorsque vous
regardez les vidéos enfants parfois il
ya un vieux pull des années 80 c'est une
émission qui m'a merci bien sûr qu'il va
s'arrêter normale à la fin il s'est
passé et merde c'est pas sûr excusez moi
vous faites des essais de son la loana
sera une manière de put alors j'entends
comme s'il avait des gars gilles verdez
alors le mieux - le mieux payé 7 antoine
de caunes gains illicites très bien jour
look anglais ou en soi mais on n'a pas
loupé normale et ils ont bien
l'intention de tout lui va
et vous n'avez pas loupé il est normal
non son coût comme des savates et
d'ombrés et sinon là le connais un peu
d'argent mais c'était la mode à l'époque
mondial pam à l'école l'argent quand tu
peux passer un droit c'est que c'est pas
bon
et la réponse de fannie mae gouverna la
voix près et le est le plus mal c'est le
moins bien raconté stablement c'est
arthur a toujours des frais non
aujourd'hui la des stylistes et vous
avez avancé une catastrophe web on parle
de maintenant sur la digue s'est arrogé
s'est arrangé non il s'est arrangé
franchement il partait de loin ah oui
mais aussi mais non là il est bien là là
on dirait oui c'est vrai c'est un autre
délire dirait coluche
est-ce que vous exagérez parce qu'il est
bien à minima oui oui mais non ce n'est
pas une connerie
la benne alors vous vous êtes super
smart de plus en plus mais alors pour
moi le gentleman ces émetteurs helmand
c'est sans doute y portent la toilette
quel qu'il soit il a un côté décontracté
que jean luc lemoine ouais ça sert à ça
les screen il échoue x d'accord alors
qu'il n'est même pas dans ses seins
alors et donc on va voir
voilà wall a tout pris sur avis de la
mer on dire un joueur de guingamp
cela signale interdite
embrasser guingampais sein de meyclub
préférant place oui et le mal habillés
et alors je l'aimé beaucoup mais moi
c'est oui des classiques il est c'est
marrant on a toujours l'air de ceux de
sortir du lit c'est une servisair
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le m je savais qu'en france ça fait
longtemps qu'ils seraient payés à 3
heures du matin faire c'est ouvrir les
boulangers ou les journalistes de merter
mais c'est bien comme ça ah ouais
d'accord merci